hi actually you know bridge what time is
over there I've had two no late [ __ ] I'm
sorry I should have checked no I wanted
to talk to you see you got there okay
yeah I just got to my dorm like cool my
roommates not here yet oh my god I'm so
nervous I miss you already
oh don't worry bridge everything's gonna
be okay the room looks good
yeah I know I guess just need some
pictures of us oh my room I just walked
in you can meet her Kelly hi I'm Kelly
I've heard a lot about you hi nice to
meet you make sure you take care of her
it's just really hard like everyone's
already got their friends and I'm all on
my own because of the dumb time I
transferred I'm sorry I wish I was there
yeah and things aren't like a home like
they call crisps chips and chips fries
and what the hell is a dime compared to
a quarter I wish I could give you a hug
things will get easier I swear
[Music]
[Music]
yes oh man that's gonna come costume
shopping with me for the 80s party
remember I was just a girl from college
she's in Andie psychology class oh cool
yeah anyway so she's gonna get a tutu
but I don't think I'm gonna because I
don't cause it's cold so I was gonna get
neon tight and maybe like oh hey I met
you at that party yeah Madison I am
Bridget yeah that poly can suck Troy
yeah it's not my favorite yeah and she's
coming over in a bit to hang out I was
awesome see I told you you'd make
friends oh yeah she's so funny did you
see her I'm SNL episode last year yes oh
my god
I didn't realize you were in my American
Lit class
yep I was supposed to take it as a
freshman I really like mr. Abrams oh
cool yeah oh really yeah yeah this is
really good
hi very good I just got busy you didn't
answer either I guess I got busy too I
want some advice actually Eric Sweeney
told [ __ ] again I don't why I stay
with him anyway Samantha ended up
talking with me about it so oh well at
least you have Samantha look I'm late
for class so okay okay
for us are you guys gonna the concert on
Saturday now my frats having a party so
what about you Bridge Bridget
yeah I miss you too but I mean look at
us we're all grown up and [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah I'll talk to you later
[Music]
[Music]
Oh morning hey you want to get breakfast
before class yeah totally
[Music]